This looks like
a lot of Top Gun,
but it's real
and it's between the United States
and Russia.
Just watching
this video is amazing
to see these two Russian fighter jets
come up to this American drone,
this Reaper drone, dump
fuel on it, clip it.
That has led to this dramatic escalation.
The Russians have been insisting
that that fighter jet,
the Russian fighter jet
did not ever make contact
with that drone.
Well,
now we can see that
the video really does belie
that explanation.
We're seeing that the fighter jet
actually comes up
extremely close to the drone.
You're watching it right there.
Starts releasing
a lot of jet fuel as U.S.
officials had said it did.
It hits that drone.
That is when the camera footage goes out.
And then when the camera footage
reappears,
you can see that the propeller of
that drone is damaged.